use su calculadora para encontrar los
valores del seno de 28 grados y de ccoo
secante de 28 grados hasta la milésima
más cercana vamos a ver esto usando
varias calculadoras primero quiero que
ustedes tomen su propia calculadora y
encuentre en el valor del seno de 28
grados pueden pausar el vídeo hasta
hacer el cálculo solo asegúrense de que
la calculadora se encuentra en modo de
grados o de gris
bueno nosotros vamos a calcular el seno
de 28 grados que damos que es el seno de
28 grados y vamos a usar una de las
calculadoras que tenemos en este sistema
operativo que es muy parecida a
cualquier calculadora científica aquí
está nos aseguramos que esté en modo de
grados o de gris no estén radiales y
escribimos en este caso 28 que son los
grados que queremos encontrar y la tecla
de seno
nos queda que es punto 46 94 etcétera
nos piden que lo redondeamos a la
milésima más cercana entonces es punto
40 y 69 lo escribimos acá como punto 46
9 ahora les voy a presentar otra
calculadora
esta es una calculadora gráfica dora del
tipo texas instrument es en particular
es una calculadora virtual una emulación
pero nos va a servir para hacer estos
cálculos vamos a realizar el seno de 28
grados aquí tengo que asegurarme de
estar en el modo de grados le doy este
botón mouse y aquí puedo ver de las
opciones tengo radial y degree nos
interesa siempre cuando hemos trabajando
con estas identidades en estos ejemplos
trabajar en modo dj en modo de grados
salimos de aquí
y realizamos seno
de 28 grados cerramos paréntesis damos
enter y nos da la misma cantidad punto
46 947 etcétera que redondeamos a la
milésima
bueno ahora nos toca encontrar cuál es
la co secante de 28 grados recordemos
que la cosa cante es la inversa o la
igualdad inversa al seno de 28 grados
con secante de 28 grados es igual a el
inverso del seno de 28 grados
que también es lo mismo a el inverso a
este resultado que tenemos 0.4 69
aproximadamente igual porque este es un
redondeo bueno vamos a resolverlo de
ambos modos voy a usar la calculadora
y de esta respuesta que ya obtuve voy a
sacar el inverso
entonces escribo 1 entre la respuesta
anterior
el resultado es 2.130 este sería el
resultado con esta calculadora por lo
que la cosa cante de 28 grados en esta
opción en esta opción de 1 del inverso
de este resultado es el número que
número es 2.1 30
punto 1
es cero
ahora voy a hacerlo de este otro modo lo
voy a confirmar con la otra calculadora
científica que tengo acá en donde voy a
tener
un limpio esto 1 /
y aquí entre paréntesis escribo el seno
de 28 grados 28 grados c no cierro
paréntesis doy enter y me va a quedar el
mismo resultado 2.130 aquí vemos que de
ambas formas podemos encontrar este
valor